how's it going bros my name is Pippa
with me my girlfriend and it's gonna be
a buy today Wow
so in case you haven't noticed we have
this thing between us which is a pie
launching machine we should have a
demonstration like that it's random how
many times you have to spin until it
splashes your face and we will roll how
many times we have to do it but you only
get to roll if you answer one of each
other's questions wrong
do you understand no well you'll get it
okay so I ask you a question that I
should know about you okay which one was
my first horror movie the first one I've
ever seen I always talk about this movie
now you don't yeah I haven't made a vita
body Blair Witch Project no no okay do I
take my glasses huh hey calm down with
the creepy okay I was scary so I okay
what's my favorite video game right now
one more damn it is it
now wait inside no you can't change I
can change because it's not correct
Mortal Kombat it's not okay would you
rather prefer to leave to play Mortal
Kombat or blood-borne for the rest of
your life I would say well coming you
didn't even know yourself I'm gonna
twist it no no way no way do it again
which one are my favorite shoes at the
moment is question I don't know the name
of your shoes oh yeah just describe them
they're white what damn from the prom
boots that you always wear every single
day thin it how how many episodes Oh the
broken podcast have been released techie
9 well you watch my podcast stupid game
what wasn't it ok you have to know this
question
you have to know oh yeah if you learned
all these I don't know what was the name
of my first ever dog
I know I know how it's the black one
right yeah yeah I don't know his [ __ ]
name guess what Baxter first of all you
little girl second of all it was called
Luna because my dad wouldn't call me
whenever my mom your questions are hard
man yeah yeah my brother I'm gonna have
my eye open
whoa you're crazy one two three what's
the name of my first pet hamster
anything poopy how many game pieces -
you never told me never told you
probably something big
sweetie okay I'm gonna give you a hand
it used to be my nickname oh oh I
remember once you told me something but
I don't remember the name put your ways
case I get a guess shorty
oh thanks
don't you like to clean yeah you crazy
girl
I want each did I get my period I knew
you were gonna ask that cuz you're the
only one I want to ask weird questions
like that now you want everyone to know
thirteen cuz that's when I got my period
what is my favorite color
okay you have two favorite colors and
you always change your mind if you do
the red or light blue which one is it
your favorite color is red but you
always pick like blue for everything so
it doesn't make any sense
miss run which one are you picking red
is it good
in high school which one was my favorite
subject not the one where I was better
than the one that was my favorite art
history yeah art history
in school which was my favorite subject
nah no hater man but you are getting mad
no not in high school now you're gonna
pay with a giant air mouth can't stop
this
oh god the cream ism yeah hope you enjoy
this video I did nothing
yeah hi boots that's a nice face you got
there would we ashamed him up
leave a like enjoy this video and do
whatever you want in life
peace be with you and the brofist man
yet stop shooting our iguana Terrier
carrot man help me circle go into circle
I thought it was icon dude you know when
you're dressed you do faster tricolor
ticket